Okay,
let's clear something up.
The enemy ghost in the shell from 1995
and the live action ghost in the shell
from earlier this year are not the same
movie.
They're both adopted from the same
universe,
originally created in the Manga by have
mooney sheer route,
but they pulled from different parts of
that universe.
Unfortunately,
the popularity of the 1995 animated
features seems to have convinced someone
that it was a good idea to graft images
and sequences from that movie onto a
completely different story.
Don't get me wrong,
I like images as much as the next guy,
but the ones in ghost in the shell 2017
don't really do it any favors.
The evocative colors in sharp contrast
to the anime are replaced by drab dark
talents that are often hard to make out
that sure animation is more likely to
have crispr lines of contrast,
but the live action movie not only fails
to recreate the beauty of its
predecessor,
it fails to understand the purpose of
that.
But take a look at these two shots.
How does each make you feel?
Okay.
For me,
the one on the left draws my attention
to the bed.
It's the brightest part of an otherwise
pretty uniformly colored frank.
If you blurt it out like this,
you can see that there is virtually no
contrast between the interior walls of
the apartment and the cityscape through
the window.
It makes for a blend bluish composition
that doesn't ask you for any further
consideration.
Or what about this one?
Well,
the immediately recognizable difference
is the light source.
Instead of coming from the bed,
the light comes from the window and it's
blown out so much that it creates this
frame within a frame effect that trout
to the apartment and leaves the major in
Silhouette.
There's great contrast here,
but the purpose of the contrast is more
important.
It's almost as if the major shape is cut
out of the city itself.
In a video I made a couple of years ago,
I spoke about how the 1995 anamae
explores the relationship between city
and person.
It uses a futuristic,
pluralistic,
dynamic Hong Kong to interrogate what it
means to build a personal identity in
the age of sidewalks.
It does this by visually framing
characters in relation to the city
around them and by giving us time to
contemplate the space where the story
takes place,
most notably in a three and a half
minute meditative sequence that allows
us to simply look at the city.
It's funny that the live action movie
ads 20 more minutes of runtime,
but can't find any time for something
like this.
In fact,
for all the cool visuals that boasts,
there is really no city at all in this
movie.
Just a digital canvas to show off.
Cyber punkish affects the way ghost in
the shell.
Twenty 17 one says to see the city is in
these elaborate soaring shots that move
and glide through the holographic
buildings,
but actual people don't see the city
that way.
One of the things that 2017 helped me to
realize is that every shot in the
montage from the anime is from the
perspective of human beings.
The camera is placed only where could
actually stand or sit or gaze out of a
window.
That's how you build a sense of place.
Not like this.
In fact,
you can learn a lot about what makes the
anime so great by watching the live
action ghost in the shell.
Let's take a look at this sequence.
For example,
one of my favorite from the original
story of the garbage man in the enemy.
We get to spend three or four minutes
with this guy and his coworker as they
work and chat.
He explains that his estranged wife
won't let him see his daughter,
so he's hacking into her mind to find
out why she's doing this.
He even chose this colleague,
a picture of his daughter,
but
he doesn't really care.
She's my beautiful,
precious angel.
See gannaway.
I'm not interested in crap like that.
In the 2017 version we get this.
You want me to pay for violin too?
Don't get me.
I love that 50 patients I do because
she's amazing,
but when she practices the thing is
painful,
right?
Why not piano?
That was 14 seconds.
You don't see these guys doing their
job.
You don't get any conversation.
In 14 seconds,
their minds are hacked and they become
zombies.
After this,
they staged the iconic fight scene from
the enemy in the water in front of the
city.
It's virtually a shot for shot remake
with a few differences like these
beautiful science versus these beige
buildings or this red shirt as a point
of focus versus this beige overcoat or
even this little smile,
a man momentarily in awe of his city.
A brief moment like that can add so
much,
but ghost in the shell.
20 17 never has time for them.
Finally,
we get to the tragic moment when the
garbage man learns that he's been
fooled,
that all his memories of his daughter or
fake implanted by a hacker.
The live action version shoots this in a
weird glass box with a man.
We've spent 14 seconds with cutting all
over the place.
The enemy takes this moment largely in
one shot,
garbage man in the harsh,
overexposed light of the truth.
The man doesn't believe it with a cop
brings out the man's photograph and asks
him what he sees.
I had a picture of her.
She was there.
She was smiling like an angel.
I'm sorry to put you through this.
Now.
Come on,
who do you see in the Nma?
We get this tragic little arc,
one that echos the larger themes of the
film and it's sequenced brilliantly
following.
This is the scuba diving scene where
major ruminates on her own identity and
following that is the montage I
mentioned before where we get to
ruminate,
where the ideas from both scenes
compound and reverberate across the
city.
In the live action movie,
the character is a throwaway.
The scene is disconnected.
The scuba diving seen as isolated as
well elsewhere in the movie at any time.
For us to dwell on these ideas is
nonexistent.
The worst part about it is that the
story ghost in the shell 2017 once to
tell is actually really good.
It's from a part of the TV series,
the standalone complex,
and it features the Revolutionary Qusay
here played by Michael Pitt whose
backstory is tragic and whose ideology
is profound.
We don't get to explore any of that
because 2017 is busy trying to
accommodate two stories.
There were interesting things about
both,
but we get nothing but the surface level
of either those who adapt works of art
should be given the creative license to
make the story work for them,
but you can't just mind the source
material for parts,
adaptations and remakes,
don't require strict adherence or
obedience or even necessarily respect
just an understanding of what made the
original so powerful in the first place.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be just a really easy
process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.